hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space 2 okay I'm
starting to trust this lady wolf I'm not
Isaac is starting two trucks this lady
Jenny I think I don't trust Joe anyway
so that's something special I'm pretty
sure I don't
learning from the last game I don't
trust any with any flesh because
everyone's out to get me
no one's mic
or that
text log found
laughs you buddy
why damnit
I got to go through there
oh is this
hat slowly rotate something to find blue
weak points then press ok
all right all until you're like blah I
got it did I that it
huh oh hello murder murder
ah don't murder me yeah buddy
tough maybe that's one of the enemies
it's supposed to brutalize me okay I
guess
look there we go
ha ha ha phones you bro of you are cool
now got Stacey's amount of stasis Oh
the hell was that seriously what the
hell was that
ah Oh nope nope not today
got ya oh you want some ooh
what is wrong with your face oh not you
you oh you're just about the hideous
most hideous thing I've ever seen oh
look at you boingy boingy boingy not so
scary now huh huh freaky their attack is
vomit attack I didn't stop it Yeah right
you go oh there yeah I get off my foot
oh man
what the hell did my stasis just
recharge on its own ha ha
my stasis to recharge on its own holy
crap
I don't need takes his recharge packs
all right then
oh I just got a stasis pack really but
it recharges on its own yeah whatever
gagging [ __ ] that's interesting
wah wah
yeah
Oh what the [ __ ] what da [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
oh okay
perfectly normal right buddy you look
fine Ella's normal
flowers lovely Oh Lucas roller chair ah
balloon
alright you pop the balloon okay Bob
yeah yeah okay why are there just
containers of cutouts like I've always
wanted that evil not Oh another power
note here the people not keep ahold of
their stupid credits what I was gonna
read it let's let's read I still don't
know how to tap through I'm supposed to
read something it's happening again the
panic the terror it's the same as on the
issue Mira I need to get out of this
place there are soldiers here and
they're trying to kill me it's like they
want to eliminate all evidence of this
place including me but some of the men
I've seen aren't soldiers I think
they're working for this woman Dana and
they want to rescue me I'm gonna follow
her route out of here I don't remember
seeing anyone else besides soldiers and
number 5 Billy he's the new Billy
a tease Jenna Jenny
that guy's Billy oxygen and use no
smoking your flavor what I smoke dope
I know
ah
oh that monster was trying to hide
this doesn't seem very good
Oh up here the red blink
I should have been obvious then again
I'm so stupid why would I think the
shoot the big blinking red thing
waving going the right way okay yes I
thank you so much for that objective
who wants some duck Jessica ah yeah yeah
wha-hoo Turner
yeah they're giving lots of power they
stay shown is that a store I saw all
year all right that their credits just
lying around
yep uh can I even get a seat losers Tory
just easy engineering moved out okay
whoa that's a lot of guns hell that's a
lot of suits
what the hell it's when do I pick huh
did I get some DLC
Wow how damn look at all these things
they're all zero holy [ __ ]
I mean hot damn look at all this stuff
when I bought dad's vase you did I got
like get like a DLC pack or something
holy [ __ ] agility advanced suit the
treehouse suit I need to read these cuz
I have no idea what the hell is going on
here okay that's all this one
engineering suit tan inventory slots 5%
armor 15 impersonal inventory slots 15
armor okay so that's better than that
one why had they all zero
that's so weird I swear I haven't I
haven't cheated or anything okay anyway
um 15 15 percent 15 okay ten percent
healed that's okay
15 percent healed obviously burning out
one dead near secret pulse rifle I swear
I'm not gonna just use the pulse rifle
again I'm going to use a plethora of
weapons um oh stasis duration that seems
like a good one
stasis recharge time stasis duration or
stasis recharge flippy-floppy
I'll go with the stay situation Plus
agility advanced suit sounds good yeah
come on now let's see what you got for
me it's time to get out of these bloody
Hospital
I don't even remember downloading any
DLC for this game
like I just basically that's fancy okay
I look downright spiffy
oh yes stretch flex the biceps slip up
to whatever the hell that is
that's cool seems logical to me all
right cool I got a suit I don't know let
me look at these guns okay jillee rivet
gun contact beam bloody force gun a
bloody foots gonna bloody flamethrower
okay
the ones that I that I promised that I
was gonna play I get for you guys here's
the line gun three different choices of
line guns okay damage reload secondary
damage speed was speeding secondary fire
let's just do four primary fire so the
heavy duty line gun I like the sound of
that
yep I'm sure okay got the heavy duty
line gun
um the other one was the force gun I
wanted to try the force gun that
refurbished plasma cutter dead space
unlock oh did I get these by beating a
dead space one maybe I've no idea maybe
the other one was the force gun just cuz
I want to give it a try they're all free
so might as well right and detonator
like this
primary damage plus 10% why not no
weapons last fall I only got two weapons
did I bang on I'm not sure anymore ah go
back what the hell go back go back
damn it to hell
all right oh I can sell off some of
these obviously I don't even stay slack
okay
I'm out of ammo for these and I didn't
see ammo in the store so okay oh I did I
did get the detonator okay all right
that's all I need then it's guys y'all
cool house does interesting surprise
okay now this is the oh they come with a
little bit okay the force gun I'll try
the force gun first
let me save cuz I took a look that's a
bit of time just getting that all
organized hey I'm really surprised
one mm-hmm I lose a good thing I picked
a harder difficulty prison row office
stuff happy why not
okay lah that's a lot of air oh I see it
yeah power node all right bring it on
I got a force gun Oh seat look a stasis
recharge it's right there I knew it I
don't even need it cuz it reach started
on its own
goodies
oh ah thank God thank God what the hell
are you what the hell was that
ma what the hell
do something secondary fire that's a gun
in useless gun debt is de gender
awesome oh yeah awesome out F come on
fine gun do something for me Linna see
right there ah I died what okay what to
hell
I guess that's sell it for you okay
anyway foreskin age getting thrown away
after this fight cuz f that that's
stupid detonators okay I like that
yep round the corner and collect all
these before Ike game not just plasmic
em oh all right
I should probably just use Oh stasis I
can stasis this thing I'm so stupid
yeah yeah are you soon
horrifying amalgamation yeah all right
now back nine gun cool ah damn it
no way get away get away get away get
away get away I said get away
hell with that ah I need stasis spacious
get away money I'm bad at this game
barely got it Oh No there you go okay
fine
move back this good old reliable clap oh
yeah I gotta jump stasis hi yeah yeah I
said just cases
that's just not laughs Oh
I gotcha ah ha ah ah come on Dana Dana
the bag technically safe
- you're floating in space ninja settle
you see I brought you here to study the
marker you found in treated your brain
with self-replicating signal the longer
you're awake the more the signal spreads
it's killing you Isaac tyvan tried to
keep it in check with memory suppressant
so you can fix it right only if you
reach me in time translation get moving
yes may I'm Jenny all right well I guess
that explains one here not how I got
here anyway that's all the time I got
for this episode either way this
starting out to be a pretty good game I
mean I'm happy so far graphic gay great
gameplay is great it's gonna be a
challenge cuz obviously I got killed in
two hits on my last boss alright but
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye